Hey Dude watch the road what the hell is
wrong with just Johnson my god can they
send him a ticket in the mail for that
Chris I know you how you feel about this
kind of stuff pay attention to the road
Josh drives me crazy it drives me crazy
I see people doing Zoom Zoom app
FaceTime why they're driving like are
you freaking kidding me you're gonna
drive 70 miles per hour on the highway
with the 6000 pound machine and be
looking at somebody in a conversation
come on everybody uh either way though I
like his play Joe Johnson all right and
I like this logo man I'm just telling
you I like it I really think it's simple
and classy I'm a big fan so far we both
got his name wrong I said Josh you said
Joe it's John it's John Johnson hey John
hey John we're even now you can be mad
at us so we got your name wrong and we
can be mad at you for being an idiot and
driving your car and looking into your
phone why you should be looking at the
road I'm not kidding it's ridiculous how
many people do this and they think it's
okay it's a problem throughout our
society I use the road rage on people
about this my family could tell you
about it I really did I would the type
that would pull up to somebody and
really be annoying to them to be like
what the hell are you doing put your
phone down it's it's just bad it's bad
for everybody who does that you're
endangering people stop texting while
driving everyone I could picture some
like little Italian guy like me giving
you a hard time like that bagel boss guy
remember he was a thing for a minute
last summer and then you get out of the
car it's like okay sorry sir all right
let's get to it all right
the Rams new logo is the reason why we
are having our draft today it is defunct
logos and uniforms that we want to see
returned and any of the rams have issued
the new logo as a precursor to their new
helmet and I'm convinced Chris that that
that that logo that horn we see in the
logo with the curve blue line and the
shading the yellow that's gonna be the
logo
they helmet just wait and see they've
had the solid white they've had solid
yellow they've had solid gold that
curved blue if you're watching on TV and
that shading that's gonna be the thing
that gets pasted onto the helmet and
when you look at the a that's white and
the RAM that's white I'm not gonna be
entirely shocked if the helmets white
although that's way too close to ripping
off the Chargers if they go with the
white helmet and a yellow horn with the
blue line on it anyway let's get to the
draft of the defunct logos and uniforms
we'd like to see you've got the trivia
question to determine the first pick go
kind of easy question here today I'm not
a big fan alright so as you said the
Rams debuted a new logo yesterday who is
the Rams all-time leading passer the
all-time leading passer for the LA Rams
would have to be man this is a trick
question because he was Kurt Warner
wasn't that did he rack up enough yards
between 99 2000 2001 2002 to overcome
John Hagel I'll guess I'll say Kurt
Warner yeah yeah oh [ __ ] sorry Jim I
threw you a curveball to by phantom as
well yeah I was hoping you would think
of his Kurt Warner and you got it wrong
so good I marry wrong yeah and he's he's
he's put two of the logo I like his idea
even better it's to enough that has
mashed together it does go well together
I do like I'm excited to see their new
uniform and what they do and they better
not go with the white helmet with the
yellow Ram thing through it then that'll
be two Chargers like you're right that
will piss off the Chargers it might piss
off me too so I don't want to see a
white helmet but with our draft and you
know logos that we would like to see
you've revived or you fasten the new
uniforms as well okay I stayed more to
the logo thing more than anything here
but I mean to me I'm going 1-1 close to
my heart
Giants baby baby
blew New York Giants I've been I think
you've heard me say this over the last
year or two anyways I would like to see
the New York Giants go back to that old
helmet that my dad Lawrence Taylor wore
that just was that dark blue helmet said
Giants underlined
to me that was the best look the New
York Football Giants ever had I
understand I'm biased than that as well
I try not to be but man you know they
did do some good things in those
uniforms and I just think it has a
unique look so that would be my number
of one right off the bat I like the
Giants and why where it is right now
it's cool don't get me wrong but I think
that Giants one is pretty special
yeah and that was the uniform that they
dusted off on a Thursday night and
that's what prompted me to make a
smart-aleck remark about Phil and Eli in
the Power Rankings December 27 2016 and
you wanted to fight me I saw that you
know one of your many snarky comments
you made during a season yes but I saw
that comment and I went man if I ever
see that Florio I am gonna put him in a
headlock
I've yet to put you in the headlock so
it's still it's still coming Mike you're
not out of the woods yet
Eli Manning had a rough game on that
Thursday night that they played so I had
dropped the Giants from three to five
and said on Thursday night Eli Manning
was dressed like Phil Simms and
unfortunately played like him so I'm
gonna go with bucko Bruce since we're
talking so much about the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers over the past week or so and
they're going back to the uniforms like
the ones that you wore you arrived in
Tampa the year after they won the
Superbowl wearing that initial phase of
red that dark red the puter with the
smaller Buccaneer logo to get that giant
flag on there now that I don't like it I
think they're still gonna have the giant
flag I like the old bucko Bruce it was
one of those things we didn't appreciate
it when we had it we had it for 20 years
we made fun of it
we reviled it we we thought it looked
ridiculous it was a cheap effort to be
like the Dolphins with kind of the
pastel and the art deco and all of that
crap or whatever whatever the right term
is I hate it at the time and I've missed
it ever since it's been gone bring back
bucko Bruce
favorites as well I mean it just there's
nothing else like it the color scheme it
just screams Florida it is a special
standalone uniform I mean come on
it had the creamsicle jerseys to go
along with it
pretty special I would love to see Brady
wearing that at least one time this year
and I don't know why Tampa wouldn't want
to do it just some another million or so
jerseys and the creamsicle color but
yeah pretty pretty special I don't know
do you
so you like that uniform better than the
current one right now you take that yes
yeah because I miss it because it's
nostalgic its it's old school I'd I'd
say I'd say go back to it now full-time
and obviously they used to do it from
time to time as a throwback that's I
think that's Josh Freeman wearing the
throwback uniform back when they were
allowed to have multiple helmets but now
you can only have one helmet per year so
you can't have a throwback that's
promised on a different color helmet
can't have a different color helmet than
the one that you ordinarily wear
unfortunately yeah well the only bad
thing about that uniform is it signifies
lots of losing man at Tampa lead the
world and losing in those uniforms
that's probably why they'll never go
back to it all right I'm going back to
the old Broncos logo you know the 1980s
John Elway got went to three Super Bowls
the Orange Crush look to me that was
special growing up and I still love that
helmet now they break out that that's
symbol every now and then and it's not
that baby blue helmet you know of course
because like what you said you got to
wear the same helmet all year long but
that orange D with the brunt you know
the Bronco coming through the middle of
it
that is one where I just look at it it
just it's a classic to me and of course
it's nostalgic to me do as well as a
young kid John Elway of course was like
the Patrick mahomes of the NFL at that
time for me so it's like so many good
memories watching him launch the ball
down the field
great uniforms great helmet awesome logo
and and I think that it's awesome when
they put that old-school D with the shoe
the snorting horse on the dark blue
helmet that's the one team that
basically says hey you know what we
can't use the old color helmet we'll
just
the old logo back on and it looks
awesome when they do that they do that a
couple of times per year and I like that
creativity for it almost creates a
hybrid of their two different uniforms
into one all right next one for me and
you know I the Patriots have been the
Platinum standard when it comes to
football excellence I have never liked
the flying Elvis logo I have never liked
the silver helmet they had the god-awful
jerseys back when Bill Parcells was the
head coach thank God they get rid of
those I like the old school Pat Patriot
with the white helmet and the and the
Minuteman who's who's getting ready to
snap the football that is awesome
awesome with the and I love the stripes
on the shoulders I'll have the red white
and blue they're Patriots they shouldn't
be silver Patriots should be red white
and blue period I do agree with that
you're right
Patriots should be red white and blue
I'm with you I do love those old
uniforms great classical look those
stripes around the shoulder the helmet
the stripe down the pants all special
the problem is just like buckle Bruce
they just signify so much losing I mean
that's to me where you know I you always
hear me talking about the bangles right
now where I want to go please rebrand we
just brought up two teams three teams
we've shown who have rebrand and once
they rebranded they showed significant
progress in their organizations the
Patriots changed our uniforms and all
sudden they started going to the Super
Bowl and becoming the winning football
team
Broncos same thing BAM Super Bowl right
away buckle Bruce out the door new
pirate flag on the helmet BAM Jon Gruden
Super Ball I mean not far after it so
that's why you keep hearing me for my
brief bread but I do like those Patriots
you nice and you're right they should be
red white and blue all right all right
ran up you're up around three yes I am I
want old school Eagles uniforms that's
what I want more than anything okay
that's that's to me whether it was just
the eagle flying and totality the full
picture or what I really like is the
Randall Cunningham Philadelphia Eagles
uniforms you know that lighter green
helmut with those real silver wings no
black outline no black in the uniform I
think when I just think of an awesome
uniform though silver pants they wore
back in the day man that is sharp I used
to like I used to be shaken in my seat
when I used to see those Eagles come out
of the out of the the tunnel at Giants
Stadium with Reggie White and and Clyde
Simmons and Jerome Brown I used to take
oh man they're gonna smash my father
today I hope he can live through this
one but I love those uniforms and I wish
the Eagles would go back to them because
I'm not a huge fan of the Eagles
uniforms right now that photo on the
screen if you're watching on NBCSN it's
Randall Cunningham 1994 it's got the
75th anniversary logo on the patch I
think it was 95 when they switched to
the current uniforms and I remember when
they made the switch Keith Olbermann
would constantly constantly rail on the
fact that they look like rollerball
numbers if you remember that movie from
the early 70s and that's kind of when
the NFL started to experiment with
different shapes and styles of numbers I
don't like it and that leads to my final
pick I want the Minnesota Vikings to go
back to their old uniforms from the 70s
top to bottom across the board get rid
of the shading from the horns on the
helmet go back to simple jerseys the
nitrification of the NFL drives me crazy
every team's got to have their own
special font of their numbers and
everything and you got to change it
every few years so we can sell more
jerseys and make more money now let's go
back to classic looks classic approach
and of course that the Vikings and I had
the jersey with me for that fateful day
in Santa Clara when the 49ers took down
the Vikings but the white jersey with
the LSU gold and purple on top man see
that's just awesome now that's that's
when it was I can't remember when it was
sometime in the 90s 96 I think when they
started putting numbers on top of the
shoulder pads get rid of the numbers on
top of the shoulder pads go back to the
70s just number on the front number on
the back with the gold and the purple
shoulder sleeves stripes that's the way
to go that and I left that one toe
number three because I knew you wouldn't
pick it but for me that would be number
one if I owned the Vikings for one
minute that would be the one thing I
would do get rid of the uniforms go back
to the 70s I hope that will end this
morning I do like those seventies
uniforms I like the uniform of looking
at NBC Sports the Sports Network right
now if you're watching I mean that was a
cool I was at that game that day that
was rainy day you know the Vikings
recovered that onside kick late to come
back and beat the Giants I think it a
wildcard playoff game pretty awesome but
Mike I asked you this do you like the
Matt helmet or do you want to go back to
the old helmet too it's just a little
shine old helmet old helmet with the
shine
I've got let me peel back the curtain
I'll tell you what I've got in my office
since you've outed me as a youth Vikings
fan who carried it into adulthood and
got rid of it once he got into this
business as much as I could
I've got some Sports Illustrated's with
Vikings on the cover that are framed and
on the wall and there's one of Fran
Tarkenton playing in Dallas and there
was something about the lighting in
Dallas with Lou the way it kind of
reacted it was awesome but it was but it
was delighting on the purple helmet in
the purple jersey when they played in
Dallas even though they were away from
home it just it had a special look to it
and that helped for all I know that's
what hooked me back when I was eight
years old but yeah I'd go back to the
shiny helmet and and and rebuild the old
Cowboys Stadium in Minnesota and play in
there with the exact lighting that they
had back in the 70s all right we got to
take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports